welcome to this video playing Michael
player Michael plan nope no previous
games and we got a Queens gambit let's
see
you're getting the exchange variation
always like this line yeah what is he
doing here and I texty five would be
very strange yeah still he's doing that
okay yeah I take the center if you
invite me to the the strange thing about
this is compared to the normal semi to
rush this a night on d 7 which it's
really not the place where it belongs
but it's probably not not totally fatal
still I'm wondering what to do Bishop d3
can take and play Bishop before and get
rid of this Bishop just like it is in
the sender to rush so this does not
smell like the refutation now they're
most like rugby one that can be useful
hmm i can i can try something here in
the cemetery says there is if it takes
now the most Bishop d3 and 97 I inserted
so after Bishop before check I actually
don't need to play Bishop t2 it's not
doing that anyway I could have played
King everyone
yeah okay I should just speed up he's
not playing any move that I'm expecting
in any way nine f6 is old so quite weird
why would you invite you 45 with tempo
that's the moves I want to play anyway
so I'm a bit strange I want to go e five
night Queenie for attacking on the on
the King side ok so let's let's just go
at him
so Queenie form yeah I'd like to really
force him to play g6 weakening the dark
squares considerably the question is
after g6 do you play Bishop age 6 come
on it's never playing a move that I
expect so I'm pretty much can just play
whatever I want yet and should calculate
too much get this like a discarded
entirely because of the Queen's the
kingside weekend weaknesses where a g6
wasn't much better of course but still
here even a six week
you know how to continue though if I go
Bishop g5 next probably I can force the
move age six and i'm not sure i can
sacrifice already on edge six probably
not don't think that this should should
win immediately I'm not sold on this
Bishop g5 move maybe em there is a
better setup certainly a good move would
be rookie one as putting pressure on the
sex porn certainty is helpful
I also like the idea to play maybe
Bishop f4 to e5 just improving the
bishop considerably and this also the
IDM to to do a rook lift on the
third-ranked like let's say rookie one
Knight to e5 and then rookie 3g 3 III h
3 this kind of maneuvers can be very
dangerous but this is all nice but it's
his move and very often the
considerations that you that you make
are completely am completely useless as
the other side is playing a move that
you totally did not expect and changes
the position considerably and this
happened all the time in this game up to
now yeah what is flex mafia it's not a
very convenient situation of course but
still yeah just a moment yeah but this
is this is right i mean just to capture
this introduces an additional
possibility rook be one rook b5 rook g5
this kind of root lift on the
fifth-ranked black will do something
against it but it doesn't know is a new
idea that's now in the position after
the pawns c5 and c3 have been traded
yeah I mean normal would be moved like
Bishop d7 maybe Bishop d7 bishop be
eight try to keep a cigarette at least
yeah ok this is it this is a net DM
getting the Queen to h5
yeah I guess there are various ways to
play form the window a pawn like rookie
won Queen h5 takes takes Bishop c4 I
probably I will win e6 but not quite
sure if this um this is sufficient
really however should to look for more
yeah maybe start with rookie one anyway
if he goes queen age five there also is
the move Queen g3 intending rupee five
yeah that's not a bad idea at least down
at the moment I don't see anything don't
see anything great for him after Queen
h5 Queen g3 however after Queen a trap I
can also take and play Bishop c4
basically winning e-cigs but I don't
want to sell to achieve play here the
ecig spawn is very weak anyway yeah
Queen g3 appetite don't see a great move
after that let's do it rookie five from
would be nice to to get in it simply
keeps more pressure on with Queen sir
still on the board
I wonder if he after after possible
rookie five if he has the move Bishop to
b6 maybe that's really the case like
Bishop d7 for example and then rookie
five push-up d6 and maybe this is a move
quite strange now but ok that let him
figure out thanks and I'm not committed
to any anything in particular I can also
just continue with Bishop f4 to e5 form
yeah this I thought ok Quincy 7 there is
95
yeah I can take him and Bishop c4 again
again winning the pawn
yes some way it feels a bit it does not
feel forcefully enough in a way I don't
want to trade Quincy em clingy five
maybe maybe Queenie five
yeah maybe this is wrong and I just
should should trade it but still have
some hopes form from some attack on the
weak King side with the Queen's on the
board it's not like I'm seeing anything
great for black here just always tricky
to decide if you should cash in this is
this poem on it six on you should just
try to keep pieces on and try to really
really punish punish the other side okay
h3 here as Queen age five you know
Bishop d2 is really really totally meek
what I won't do that age three Queen age
five nothing great William
why should I play Bishop e2 a.m. yeah
rookie to looks like a very very weak
back rank maybe this is totally
irrelevant but
okay come on I don't want to spend ages
here yeah Vic quite as it is quite often
if you once you have decided to do not
take the pawn you come to the point
where you think you can I did not take
the bleep on at least then I knew what
to do okay
young are nice but it's not like I'm
winning jimmy-luke be one can play
Bishop c6 maybe even that but ok i have
f 3 and then i can take only six ok Kim
just 61 rook c7 preventing Bishop c6 in
any case yeah it is a comfortable
position but it feels like I should have
I should have gotten more in a way this
is not nothing nothing particularly
great yeah maybe Queenie form get the
Queen's off come on not sure really yeah
maybe you can even play Queen h5 there
should be two yeah it's not very
convincing really yeah I should have
just taken the pawn as simple as that
yeah your Queenie force also not a very
successful move its trading himself ok I
thought now after the pawn take upon
takes I have 94 2d6 night f4 Bishop a 6
is not very much of a problem
you
yeah I guess Bishop a6 controlling the
c8c eight square
okay well 96 looks like the normal
normal move
ya author that that's that's starting to
him be comfortable again I believe he's
got this active rook really can I
exchange it with rookie one let's try to
do that it goes night before at some
point I have Bishop c4 all the time
check the moment you at the moment his
rook is somewhat dominated by the night
okay when where do you go of course 96 f
4 is something that I that I love to do
expanding the majority and supporting
the e5 pawn the night really belongs on
d5 I'm trying to cover the c7 square
yeah ok so here rook see one that should
be right with Bishop c4 intending to
capture in rook c7 these kinds of moves
kibum keep some pressure still maybe f4
was interesting
q I'm covering letter and I can also
activate the King next king of two at
least
maybe night before really as this is an
idea he needs never doing that okay here
of nite CH second night a seven but it's
probably not very good okay playing
playing this to prevent night night to
be form yeah i can i can give the check
here actually and then we should be
seven check just just trying to take it
and play rube c7 or take it and get the
King to deform this kind of idea yeah ok
i will definitely take it now go to d4
so let's consider is some there's some
point I can give this check awesome or
here then the check takes takes Knight a
seven well that's that's not a good good
technical play I think I go to deform
might play Bishop c4
yeah this is probably too just push the
majority and f5 f5 next
the immediate f5 also was possible then
he has rook g8 not not terribly
dangerous but okay
mff text extra chief i am not wear this
as i said not decisive or anything but
feels a bit unnecessary to allow any any
kind of play that's that's not helping
that's what's the easiest way to do it
I not I'm not totally sure about them
about them the best technical way to to
play this position
yeah now the pawn should be ready to go
they're probably here winning winning a
tempo and then f5
oh it's good to have many pieces on dark
squares if the opponent has got a light
squared Bishop always feels like there
is no not much dangerous so have been
happening to you possibly black resigns
champ that was surprisingly tough after
the the opening here probably mostly
because I just played it bad lame that
this is very very likely yeah here I
expected g65 was so shocking it's quite
remarkable that I couldn't couldn't find
anything great yeah that that's just
yeah I'm just not playing well Bishop g5
is much stronger yeah I simply failed to
consider that that this that this is a
good good way to play that's the
disastrous position I didn't I didn't
consider this at all I mean why does
keeping an edge in many ways but I
should simply take the pawn like this
here and Goodwin e6 this is just easier
the way it went down I always keep
something but I feel like taking the
pawn was the better of the better
decision yeah idea that did it's really
not nothing much but with some
inaccurate moves here rook rook to e8
was very strange just probably take it
and now when we would night arriving on
d6 I think this was important getting
rid of the active route back and now I
will this this was of course very
helpful losing those moves giving me the
opportunity to expand with F
and here we are we are quickly
approaching areas where why this winning
check yeah my age 5 is strong him age 5
strong check yeah that's also very very
much winning what I did seems to to keep
the the winning position but it felt a
bit found a bit shaky in a way I don't
know I thought there should be something
easier but as long as he doesn't get get
any definite counterplay it was probably
all right i hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching